I really do enjoy hanging out with Scott
with the kids but like if we're doing
things socially I just don't really know
how to act on Sunday season 13 premiere
of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Kourtney and Scott opened up about their
complicated relationship I worry about
my actions setting you off since you
have been doing well there was a time in
our life when your actions would affect
me now I've got an older and realized
all the responsibility I have to take on
like no offense to you but no matter
what you do I can't change my life over
it Chloe got candid about her beau and
be a star Tristan Thompson even though
she was hesitant to talk about him with
her sister Kim Kourtney and I tell each
other literally everything cuz we don't
pry too much we all know to not tell Kim
anything unless we want to tell her
every last detail the show ended with a
preview for next week's episode centered
around Kim's horrifying Paris robbery
incident last October it makes me so
upset to think about it but like either
they're gonna shoot me in the back or if
I make it and they don't if the elevator
does not open in time or the stairs are
locked then like I'm